well it's gonna be really hard not to
chat with you you guys going oh it's
okay exactly well the two of you wind
your voices too obviously these two
stars of the film so a lot of your work
consists of voiceover and so you are in
the recording studio did you guys have
time to spend together before you
actually jumped into the recording
studio I mean what the dogs are with
each other with each other and when the
dogs
we'd actually met in London previously
and hung out together
um and so it was also sort of one of
those happy accidents then it was like
oh my god we're gonna be working
together so that we had the good fortune
of having had some great social time
together yeah and then the cool thing is
we were always in the studio together
which sometimes is rare sometimes when
you get these performances people are in
different countries or they don't want
the opportunity to meet but we were
together which meant we got to do lots
of improv and figure out scenes sort of
as we were going in and come to know
each other yeah you can really feel it
though as a member of the audience and
watching the film the chemistry is there
and you guys bring these two to life
even more so what about with rose and
Monty here were you guys able to get to
know them no we you know they were off
doing the you know arguably the real
work yeah Georgia Sun I've met Monty
briefly at the end of shooting when I
went to set for a second but leaning
into your counterpart Huma hazmat my
counterpart how did that go it went fine
he's so well trained that you know and
she's just like huh yeah what scene is
she is she's in the dog pound scene okay
gotcha dog I see yeah before that it's
hilariously they put her she's in a cage
and barking and whatever but if you ever
like a much deeper bar telling what are
your earliest memories of the animated
version ladyandtramp
sounds trite but like I feel like it was
the first time I thought about romantic
love like you thought about a date you
know yeah forget it I was like I want to
go do those dates right that spaghetti
scene just gets you every time and it
gets you again and this foul that's a
little meatball hand over with the nose
you two are a match made in heaven
hell yeah but okay so the Spaghetti seen
obviously iconic it's how a lady in the
[ __ ] have their date night over
spaghetti and meatballs so what would be
your ideal cuisine for a night out care
about
if you're both doing their way that was
kind of like I'm like a myth what I mean
like I've never like I don't kiss
someone his head gargling like garlic
I'm like well it's cuz you like garlic
so yeah if you didn't like they're like
you have an issue
yeah like also cooking with garlic on a
date sometimes it gets your finger right
and it is not it likes Monst and yeah it
doesn't I get the argument slightly but
I still love garlic but you gotta both
be in on it and lady is the spoiled
little lady that she should be you're
right she's living the life of comfort
and luxury and like I said spoiled so
you guys are proud parents of peaches as
well
yeah do you feel like you ever spoil
your future are you sure they're more
than yourself sometimes I actually
haven't I don't have here at that stage
yet where I leave the house for like 15
minutes I'm like she's been alone for
too much I have to believe I'm
definitely like he's in a dog spa right
now Oh living the dream
yeah mine's doing a junket at BBC yeah
we're doing rotation hard hidden stuff
right there of course obviously about my
cameo in this yeah exactly we got to say
we as was the rest of the world have all
been excited that James would instakill
I know right who knew who knew who
woulda thunk surprises home for sure and
she really surprised us all with that
epic first post at the entire friends
cast rewriting what did you make of that
I mean what everyone else made of it
yeah is there gonna be a sequel yeah
super cool yeah it was and literally
broke Instagram it I know literally she
actually texted me said she said you
haven't followed me on of course I've
followed you and she's like no you have
it then I realized I was one of the
people caught in the glitch ah so I had
followed comment I said was there an
actual she created and it literally
broke Instagram like yeah like like
people like we're having trouble being
recognized as following this is breaking
news the other day yeah my only making I
did know that she joined in
gotta give her a follow good stuff well
it's good that I waited until past the
glitch knows me try seamless at this
point we worked the glitches out for
y'all when it comes to posting on social
media for both of you who were on that
platform in particular what's kind of
like the one thing you keep into account
when posting on its permanent so you
have to delete it later no everything's
worthy of a delete yeah no I just like
you know you just like post something
and it lives for a minute and then you
and then and then you make it go with oh
yeah but that's something that that's
like a way of post it's like curation
yeah I like the way images look together
but you know I did think about this I
was having a funny conversation with my
friend yesterday where I was like I
realize I'm gonna be asked about the dog
that I just adopted because I posted it
on Instagram yeah and I think just
issues of privacy that come up I mean
obviously my dog I think my dog is a
very private person I don't know yeah he
wants people if he wants people to know
he may like I just talked about him at
the dog spa maybe he wants to be it's a
spawn oh my god so I think I think about
that he's like ma yeah I just want to
talk assembler is like the emoji like
heart emojis all over the period be like
we're not here for you dude I do which I
get all the time well yeah yeah it's a
better post always if she's okay she's
in subject matter yeah alright well
we're getting the snaps we're getting
that's I'm sorry my my co-star left oh I
didn't want he's like yo I'm gonna take
five
Monte's literally sitting over there
just like
you